ladies and gentlemen this is the story
about how edward snowden
got hired to do some press piece and
instead
ambushes the guy live for accusations
that this guy thought he would get away
with
and we're gonna talk about everything
but let's talk about ed first right
the man myth the legend look he was born
june 21 1983
famous and infamous for copying and
leaking highly classified nsa docs you
guys know the whole thing
we found out thanks to snowden that the
fbi is watching us right now
through your webcam probably like his
methods or not it's undeniable that he
risked
everything for the sake of the american
people he was making bank
now he's like in russia somewhere
freezing or whatever so he risked it all
for getting the truth out there because
he's what we call an ideologue right
someone
who doesn't get motivated by traditional
things like money or things like this
instead
he lives for like an ideal in this case
the truth getting out there and those
kinds of people by the way
they're dangerous and admirable because
they can't be bribed or bought
which is why when a wealth guru invited
snowden to shill some kind of wealth
summit thing
everyone was perplexed including snowden
himself
who accepted the invitation only to slam
dunk the guy
live in front of his entire audience
let's watch this together
okay this is amazing and so i have to
ask
it's very unusual that you booked me for
this conference because you know as a
whistleblower it's my obligation
i think personally and professionally to
ask is this you
my guy just did it with the this you
with an article
accusing him of a ponzi scheme 4.4
million dollar ponzi scheme dude to
understand
how amazing this is to understand what
led up to this
look i gotta walk you guys back for who
this organizer is
right the organizer the guy
on screen right here is sunil
tulsiani of brampton ontario okay in
2008 and 2009 he sold
unregistered bonds which reports say
turned out to be part of a
4.4 million dollar ponzi scheme by the
way stand it's gone
that was sold to 80 investors who were
part of his private investment club
okay sunil was then banned from trading
securities for
life by the ontario securities
commission and then later charged with
breaking that ban
in 2015 with unregistered trading now
you might be thinking
with all these allegations accusations
bans that would be enough to prevent
someone
from advising other people about their
wealth right breaking into this fake
guru seminar circuit but of course
you'd be wrong sunil has appeared with
many
of the biggest fake guru name right like
greg cardone
look at this dude grant is shilling this
guy's event for him
watch fifty dollars to how much fifty
dollars to fifteen thousand dollars
i would strongly advise you invest in
the fifteen thousand dollar go sit with
the players
yes he goes don't spend a thousand on
this guy fifteen thousand
you can't do that okay buy a fifty
dollar ticket upgrade on your weight
make a commitment to being there make a
commitment
to say because guess what man if you
can't do 15 grand
you're not gonna buy any real estate in
canada that's right yo dude if you can't
spend 15k
on a real estate court bro what are you
doing what are you
these guys are such clowns and look it
wasn't just him it wasn't just grant
cardone right
uh he got in with kevin hart kevin
harrington also
of shark tank and co-hosted stages with
all these guys and he did that as
recently
as march of 2020 my point is because in
spite of promoting this 4.5 million
dollar scheme or whatever
to his private investment club this guy
is still crushing it as you can see with
the biggest names
in this fake guru world right
everybody's endorsing this guy
and his immo is to throw big events with
the biggest names in the world and
nobody
ever calls him out so like think about
that understand that this guy lands
snowden and he thinks it's gonna be just
like
all his other interviews that's the
context of this so he hypes up the zoom
event
he hypes this up for his private
investment club whatever thinking that
snowden's gonna legitimize him he
thought
this guy wasn't gonna background check
him but the only problem is it's edward
snowden you dummy
so this guy comes on the show does a
five minutes google search
and does what none of these people have
had the balls to do
to say to this guy which is uh
this you um this idea of whistleblowing
it's really remarkable to me
people go through the day and they
become
so familiar with this sense of
wrongdoing with seeing things like i saw
in the office
and hoping somebody else would do
something about it returning blind eye
going it's not my problem these are not
my people it doesn't impact me
oh my gosh it's like he's talking to all
these guys who refuse to call him out
who all share stages with this guy
never say anything they just never say
anything what you got
securities banned what i'm not gonna say
anything's not my problem and so i have
to ask
it's very unusual that you booked me for
this conference because you know as a
whistleblower it's my
obligation i think personally and
professionally to ask
is this you yes
look at that silence yes because i think
that it is
yes and i think that the things that
i've heard tonight make me very
uncomfortable
with this event i think that makes me
very uncomfortable and everyone involved
with this
should really question is this the kind
of association
that they want to have are you going to
be able to deliver on the promises that
you're making them
i sure hope to god that you will but my
advice to everyone on this goal tonight
everyone looking at this
is look up uh what you're getting
involved in if you
spend money are you sure that you want
to spend it or do you want to charge it
back
and i gotta think hard about if you want
to continue this because for me
ladies and gentlemen for tonight i don't
thank you so much and good night
[Laughter]
wow all he can say is wow
this is the greatest clip of all time
dude edward is a legend
forever he's goad he's already goaded
but he's goaded forever for this
this is the face of a man who did not
know he was about to be caught out on
his own live stream
let's uh let's take like few minutes
break and i'll write i'll be right back
this is totally unexpected i bet it is
and i'm so sorry that this has
happened i bet you are look if you guys
notice private investment club
that's by the way what's named in the
2008 2009 like uh
you know whatever complaint whatever
that is
the charges he solicited his private
investment club people for this scheme
he's still running the same private
investment club like that's just the
crazy part about it is like why would
you go back
into this after you know what this guy
has done
so they shut this stream off right they
take a break
whatever now here's where i want to give
you guys the follow-up this is why you
come to coffeezilla for the extra
context because this guy jack paulson on
twitter
followed this up and live tweeted the
whole response
so apparently they went on break uh a
guy
on a hot mic who didn't know it was on
said wasted every day apparently he also
ordered a medium iced coffee while
they're on break okay so then they come
back
and sunil says that the problem is that
somebody wrote a
click bait article okay he says if i
stole millions of dollars i would not be
here don't be so super sure i was never
charged criminally
which that's amazing you know what the
actual uh
headline one of his headlines is sunil
is charged quasi-criminally yeah guys
hey he was never charged criminally
he was charged quasi-criminally
that has to be the slimiest way to get
out of something you go hey i'm not a
criminal according to the ontario
securities commission i was only charged
quasi criminally it's clickbait dude hey
you know how the ontario securities
commission is known to write clickbait
guys and look at this point if snowden
has told you guys hey don't get involved
in this i wouldn't get involved
if you get involved in this i'm sorry
it's on you it's like if enron reopened
their doors and you invested in them
like we already have this thing with the
private investment club we already have
the
reports on it it's done it's done he's
still running it you guys are still
investing in it don't do it
i just oh man when i saw this i i almost
cried
tears of joy man snowden is a legend
for this forever and it takes guts to
call it out man
oh man this is so funny and listen it's
to some of you who are going to say look
can't a guy get a second chance i am
about second chances
just not about managing your money if a
banker if anyone has ever been banned or
had any financial misdoings
never trust that person with your money
look bernie madoff only ran a ponzi
scheme once
what about the second chances it's like
no something's
it that's it like if you trusted eye
surgeon right to do eye surgery and they
mess up on your eyes
you don't give them a second chance to
go back for the second you say no
i think i'm good i'm gonna go to a new
guy i've already been charged with
sketchy stuff
we're done we're finished so thanks to
snoda for calling this out i just want
to show you guys this that's basically
it
did you learn anything did you get a
good laugh out of this thanks for
watching uh i'll see you guys in the
next one
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee